are there healing modalities for cancer
and very and and and tumors and
um you know medical conditions that are
life-threatening 100 yes and in fact I
was at a classified medical research
facility in El Paso years ago on the
border of Mexico I think the actual
facility might have tunneled down and
was under under Mexico
um and they had technologies that were
these very Advanced trans-dimensional
physics electromagnetic systems where
they could repair a severed spinal
column if say someone's paralyzed from
the you know and they had Technologies
where if you had a missing limb you know
people have phantom pain but if you
study it sounds very metaphysical but
there is what the mystics would call the
astral body or body of light well that
energy field is still there it's very
subtle yeah but they had technologies
that could attach to that and then
regrow the limb that was missing
so I mean as a doctor I went in there
and I went wow I mean you know because
I'm using the best I have access to as a
doctor at the time which is you know
kind of caveman era stuff when I think
about it but um
yeah yeah on the chest tubes you know
but it works I mean you know you can say
yes thank God for medical like modern
medicine right now like even as it is it
saves a lot of lives but we could be so
much further along this is the point so
then then you just extrapolate this
across uh every other discipline you
know
um one of the whole last part of the
Lost century and actually there's a
website for the lostcenturyfilm.com
because we crowdfund all of our our
films we don't allow a corporation or a
media company to fund it because I don't
trust them you know what I'm saying he
he who has the gold rules you know
they're always going to want to take out
stuff nope I have final cut over
um I have total control over what it
goes out but what happens is that
you'll see in this last segment the last
part of that film is a whole we we spent
a lot of money doing Motion Graphics
showing what the world would look like
after all this begins to come out in 50
years 100 years 200 years a thousand
years on and on because I predict that
within about 20 years of the disclosure
of these Sciences
we would have no poverty in the world
and no pollution the world would be
restored to a pristine State and because
most of the expense of everything is the
energy associated with digging it up out
of the ground manufacturing it shipping
it think of that at every stage of that
supply chain and what have you it's all
energy intensive and where's the energy
coming from oil gas coal about you know
90 percent we have a little bit of
renewable but it's almost trivial
um at this stage and it's never going to
be significant until we bring up these
high-tech classified Technologies but
unfortunately we estimate that there's
over 800 900 trillion dollars
in Assets in these old dinosaur era
smokestack commodities
and unfortunately that's a lot of power
and a lot of powerful interests so we're
we're kind of stuck you know we either
have to find a way to bring these
Technologies out and try to give a
softer Landing as possible to everyone
working in oil gas coal Public Utilities
because you're not going to need a power
company or transmission lines because
every single home and business and your
car will have its own electromagnetic
power plant
and this is not an urban myth by the way
this we will prove we have you'll get it
from the ground the ground will be your
uh you're getting it from the fabric of
space-time so think of it this way with
the ground right Tesla was from the
magnetic yes some of his now he back
then he didn't quite know he knew the
effect with a very high voltage system
um and I think a lot of Faraday in the
late 1800s others I'm not sure they
quite understood the physics of it
because it hadn't been elucidated uh it
is understood now frankly and and I
think that when the public understands
what's at stake here
I think whether you're a good old boy
like the guys I grew up with in North
Carolina with a pickup truck or you're
you know a policy want concerned about
energy Supply or the environment or what
have you you're going to say well me if
this is true and it is then we need to
at least put some effort into an r d
effort one of one of the punch lines of
the film it's only showing the future
but showing the pathway to get there how
do we get from here to there I think we
now here's what I think I think we need
to have an open source energy research
lab
now you know you need 50 to 100 million
dollars in seed money but I mean in
Silicon Valley they put a billion
dollars in every kind of lame brain idea
every week
um they really do I mean it's you know
they're called unicorns you know
somebody you know a new video to show
your kitty cat playing the piano or some
other frivolity but I know like
commentary but I think that really it
would not be that difficult I think in
within about two years of standing up an
open source lab open source means no
patents no intellectual property and I
would have the lab live streamed with
blockchain backup so that every
breakthrough week meet a whole lot of
people with no egos then
well you have to have people who care
about humanity and the Earth and Gaia
than about the almighty dollar
um and you know I think that's possible
they're philanthropic people out there
um I gave up my medical career to do
this what's the role of you had
mentioned it earlier and I just thought
of it because one of the questions I had
was about the moon what's the role of
NASA you know if we like lost the
technology speaking about technology and
you know open sourcing and letting
everyone contribute it's like what's the
role of NASA right now if you if you
were to take every agency and part of
the government there would be a very
small highly compartmented deep black
aspect of it so that does exist in NASA
all of them now that means 99 plus
percent of everyone that works for NASA
has no knowledge of it uh my uncle was
Northrop Grumman that had the contract
to build a lunar module that landed on
the moon the first time with Neil
Armstrong and uh as a little boy that
was a thing to be involved with but
um the reality is he was not read in to
this level at all because he was dealing
with jet thrusters and Rockets and all
that
um so I think that you know the best way
to describe it is I have a very good
friend who used to work for a JPL she
had proportional labs in California and
he Dr Richard Haynes and uh he worked
with me in the 90s on a lot of this and
he said yeah NASA we call it white
collar welfare reasons because we know
we're not doing anything I mean those of
us who understand this subject
you know we're making nice salaries and
we're doing make-believe whatever and
we're putting uniforms and the helmets
but what yeah we're putting you know I
told someone that you know the SpaceX
with Elon Musk yeah I said Rockets were
really cool in the 40s and 50s
but right now it's like really come on
dude
um but I mean he doesn't want to touch
this because I think he he thinks you
know he'd be assassinated why did we
lose the technology to go to the Moon we
didn't lose the technology it just the
ones that were these anti-grab devices
um they never wanted the public to know
the traditional rocket systems
um and going there into that put the guy
bash on that after the landing because
when we landed there were other assets
there what was there
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen